yo guys and suppose all I don't know
about that bad we're gonna be trying on
fashion to overstuff today I'm super
excited I know about fashion over
because of the internet I've seen it on
Instagram and I'm excited they have a
men's line I don't know much about
fashion over but I like style so I'm
down to give it a shot if it works for
cardi B it'll work for me I'm guessing
so I think the only accounts I file on
Instagram are like dog accounts I have
no idea what fashion Nova is this seems
like as good a way to buy clothes as any
I guess we do we really look like a
boyband the colour I've never worn
anything this pink I know I'm and I want
you I want you I'm not huge on graphic
tees I like my tees mostly just felt
like like black solid white grey that
fits pretty good though it feels a
little loose I bet if I wash it it'll
fit perfectly I like this jacket though
no yes the jacket is nice I love the way
the pants fit like when I was putting
them on they felt a little stiff
but then once I got them actually on my
body I was like oh they have more gear
than I thought 50 bucks for a pair of
pants it's definitely more expensive
than I hmm
looking about the same as a Uniqlo or
something like that the first look I
could I dig it this is definitely
something like a like I would just go
out out and about outfit I've never
looked like this before we were just
saying his regular style is more like
dad we got some more clothes to try out
let's do it you look like a like a
hipster rock star that's actually
literally the coolest of his body will
let me look I really like this but it
also totally kind of freaks me out cuz
it's a lot going on I'd never wear stuff
like this your skin tone I like it it
fits good do you have a little chest
here going to get a little a little
Miami vices and I also like how
lightweight the sureties I like these
pants these are very much Airport it
looks like you're in the airport going
to Hawaii
yes exactly I think you also look at
with the jacket oh I love it
I'm really so size wise I feel good
about sizes as a medium so far so good
Sam I think the shirt fits great I like
the flow enos of it it's fun
to the next last outfit yeah let's do it
want to do this okay you look good I
like this I am upset that I did not get
one of everything I would love to see
you like rocking this on a regular basis
- I tried on this new pair of pants
similar to the other ones are kinda like
khaki that material so all the pants
seemed about to be about the $50 range
which makes it hundred and ten dollars
for an honesty that's about right yeah
and this you can wear with anything else
this is a again anything else yeah the
thing I like about these clothes is that
they give you options to like be really
stylish without having to try hard
whatsoever I'm so surprised yeah like
that like I was able to like piece
together just some random box yeah yeah
well be really like about all this stuff
I feel like immediately your photo shoot
ready it started to make sense I get why
it's so big on it sir it does look
really good on you guys I dig it
my cardi B now you're so close
[Music]